le confinement est difficile à vivre
pour bon nombre de français la situation
l'est d'autant plus pour les personnes
sans domicile fixe et nos équipes sont
allées à la rencontre de quelques uns
d'entre eux cynthia elle lauvergeon
nicolas coupet et grégoire doucet un
confinement à l'extérieur si le
gouvernement a annoncé réquisitionner
les hôtels pourri de confiner les sdf
dans des conditions décentes la réalité
du terrain est encore bien différente
adrian à la rue depuis son arrivée en
france a bien contacté quelques
établissements hôteliers mais n'a reçu
que des réponses négatives
j'ai trouvé quelques roses at elle mais
semble un des sens complet parce qu'ils
sont beaucoup dans l'axé à tellement de
gens qui sont dans la rue et même les
français qui sont travaillés travail
plus difficiles association des bords
des difficultés pour se nourrir
adrian témoigne de l'extrême difficulté
de son quotidien quand même faire la
manche devient mission impossible pas
c'est tellement très difficile ne
trouvent pas de travail
y'a pas à dire que dans la 2 donc
c'était long très difficile des médias
des les associations et son blindé et a
pas de place la croix rouge c'est qu'ils
me donnent des vêtements mais restait du
coeur il père et un frère aussi c'est à
beaucoup des gens qui sont dans la rue
donc c'est long très difficile bein
donne à manger viêt moi je prends ma
douche je peux me reposer
mais il peut pardonner logement il peut
donner autre chose donc le serbe est
difficile je dors mal à color c'est dans
une gare c'est la seule qui espère l'es6
et calme si la plupart des policiers se
montrent compréhensifs à son égard
il affirme que d'autres l'ont verbalisé
étant donné qu'il n'avait pas sur lui la
fameuse attestation dérogatoire si une
amende de 135 euros
parce que j'avais pas le attestation de
sortir je les dis que je fais dave sur
l'a12 donc j'ai pas un endroit mais dit
roy ledroit où tu peux aller sinon
plusieurs fois sinon de trappes te fais
contrôler et à pas les papiers pour son
style de la maison est faite de
domination d'autres comme nassim
parviennent à se procurer le précieux
sésame pour autant les autres problèmes
du quotidien de la rue persiste le
produit que la ftf les plus hauts
commissariats et doux
regardez il disait on s'en fout et il
s'en faut de nommer pas devant mais pas
de rien mais pas de même de même mon
insistance la plm répond même pas ils
sont restreints et tout comme je vous
dis ça sert monde est dans la merde mais
moi je suis en train de chercher un
appartement vide pour l'ouvrir au delà
des quelques mesures annoncées par
l'état
les sans abri compte plus que jamais sur
des mouvements de solidarité nationale
pour les aider à traverser cette épreuve